let's talk now about the outlook for
2022
one of the
conventional wisdoms in terms of
democrats running in midterms and in
presidential elections one of the
conventional wisdoms is you run on the
economy mostly
sometimes uh there are other issues that
that have a big impact but you mostly
run on the economy and in general it's
believed and i believe the polling
normally bears this out to be true
running on gun safety isn't good for
democrats in national elections and
running on abortion isn't good for
democrats in national elections and
historically i believe that that's been
true and we've seen polling to that
effect and we've talked to experts who
say these are not when democrats run on
gun safety it doesn't really motivate
other democrats to get out and vote and
it often will motivate republicans to
come out and vote against those
democrats the polling this election
cycle now in the aftermath of roe v wade
being overturned by the supreme court
and in the aftermath of republicans
willing to do very very little if
anything when it comes to gun safety
okay it looks like there's going to be
this kind of very small bill but it's
not really going to deal with the major
issues along
gun safety it actually may be exactly
what democrats should run on for the
midterms
if the attention span of the electorate
is still going to keep those issues in
the forefront of voters minds in
november
which is four and a half months from now
so let's look at the polling first and
we have two sets of polling here first
of all we have a new cbs news poll
americans react to the overturning of
roe v wade most disapprove most call it
a step backward and um when you look at
the data
um among all americans only 41
approve of the supreme court overturning
roe v wade and 59
disapprove and when you look at women
specifically it is even more skewed only
a third of women approve of the supreme
court overturning roe v wade and
two-thirds of women disapprove now this
shouldn't surprise us in the sense that
we've been tracking public attitudes
towards abortion since roe v wade and um
support for abortion being legal in most
cases has increased ever over the last
50 years every time the poll is done
support for roe v wade support for
abortion being legal in most cases has
gone up
so that's not a surprise also from the
poll 52 percent of americans believe
that overturning roe v wade is a step
backwards
whereas only 31 percent believe that
overturning roe v wade is a step forward
17 percent believe that it is neither uh
without question the world looks at the
united states overturning roe v wade
what we have seen i mean look at my
country of argentina which was very much
behind on abortion rights in the last i
don't remember it it feels like it's
been the last five years in the last
five years going in the direction of
legalizing abortion most countries go in
the direction of legalizing the united
states now going backwards and this is
what conservatives talk about when they
say conserve they don't even mean
conserve the status quo they mean go
back to the 1950s or even beyond in
certain cases so not not a surprise
there
and then um what will the impact of roe
v wade being overturned beyond women's
lives
56 percent of americans believe that
this will make women's lives worse while
only 16 percent believe that overturning
roe v wade will make women's lives
better and then lastly on the question
of will they go further
57 percent of americans believe it is
likely that that next the supreme court
will try to limit same-sex marriage and
55 percent of americans believe that the
supreme court will next or soon try to
limit access to birth control something
that i have been talking about
extensively with many of you for a long
time so
that to me signals
this time around
running on they're taking our rights
they're taking abortion as a right
and they want to come for same-sex
marriage i mean clarence thomas wrote it
in his opinion
that may actually be a good idea these
midterms second issue is gun safety and
we've looked at some of these numbers
before americans overwhelmingly support
the vast majority of gun safety
regulations that have been proposed
there's some pew research data which vox
summarized into a very good graphic
which i have on this on the screen now
and let's see if i can zoom it in a
little bit there
when you ask about what about mental
health restrictions on firearms um close
to 90 percent of americans the black dot
here is the overall um close to 90
percent of americans support that
more than 80 percent of americans
support
81 support background checks on every
purchase no gun purchases that would be
exempt
79 of americans support uh rather oppose
concealed carry without a permit there
are states where you don't need a permit
to concealed carry you can just do it um
almost 80 percent of americans are
against that a 77 support family
initiated red flat flag laws where a
family could say hey this person is not
stable they should not be able to uh
have firearms 70 support
police-initiated red flag laws and even
these provisions that have lower support
still have nearly two-thirds support
bans on high-capacity magazines 64
and bans on assault style weapons 63 so
i believe at this point it is completely
clear these are
good issues for democrats to run on this
time around what are the counterpoints
well the counterpoints are democrats
haven't been particularly strong on a
lot of these issues either in terms of
what they've been able to accomplish now
you can then say well but that's because
of republican obstructionism sure sure
but is there credibility in democrats
saying we're going to take care of these
issues we're going to get back to that
issue a little bit later in the show
another counterpoint these issues seem
very
um
one-sided and important and relevant
today to voters but what about on
november 8th we've got four and a half
months of
pumping up on right-wing media oh fuel
prices and inflation and the border and
ukraine and these issues that are used
to attack joe biden even if they have
very little to do with joe biden
will guns and abortion still be on the
minds of voters come november 8th how
long is the understandable outrage about
roe v wade
and gun safety going to last and then
and then lastly and this is what we'll
get back to when we look at some viral
uh a viral interview clip a little bit
later
are there
enough voters who see democrats as
credible on these issues to say okay i'm
outraged about what happened
but do i believe that voting for
democrats is the way that we're going to
improve the situation we'll talk about
that a little bit later but in the
immediate let me know you can find me on
twitter at dpakman do you believe that
guns and abortion
in this particular election cycle are
good issues for democrats to run on let
me know find me on twitter at deepakman
and we'll keep talking about it after
the break